which shows the length of the rectangle
measured correctly all right
so here we have this green rectangle
and let's see how did we measure we have
one centimeter right over here and then
we put another
centimeter right over here and they say
two real two rulers measure the
rectangle side to side
well this makes sense because we can say
look if from here to here from the
beginning of the rectangle to the middle
is one centimeter and then it's another
centimeter that gets us to the other
side to the right side then we know that
this is going to be two centimeters long
one
and two so i'm pretty sure this is
measured correctly but let's just make
sure that the other two don't really
measure the rectangle correctly
so this one right over here
you have one centimeter and another
centimeter but you're leaving a gap
right over here and you can't measure
you can't leave a gap here you want to
measure what this distance is and you
notice that this ends to the right of
the right of the rectangle so this isn't
a good way of measuring it and this way
you're not going all the way the entire
length of the rectangle so this you're
coming up short you need to measure the
entire length you just start on the left
side which they did but you need to go
all the way without any gaps and without
overlapping the rulers in any way to get
to this side so this isn't right either
so let's keep doing these
which shows the length of the eraser
measured correctly
so this one well once again there's some
weirdness over here i don't even know
what's happening but the entire ruler
isn't even getting to the entire length
of this rectangle so this isn't measured
correctly and they say two rulers
measure the eraser and overlap oh i see
this is kind of the ruler's a little bit
transparent so this one is overlapping
with the one underneath so you
definitely don't want to do that you
want to put them right next to each
other without a gap and you want to get
all the way to the edge of this
rectangle
so this one you have a gap and you're
actually going you're actually going
beyond the edge of the rectangle so
that's not good here you have no overlap
and no gap right over here they're just
right next to each other and we're
starting at the left side of this
rectangle and we're going exactly to the
right side we're not over overstepping
it or we're not under doing it so this
is going to be right
this is a lot of fun
let's do okay this is interesting what
is the length of the floor of the bank
in meters this is a picture of a bank i
guess this is the big money in the bank
those are big dollar bills and those are
big coins drag the ruler to make the
measurement and this is in meters so i
can click on this
and then i can put it remember i wanna i
don't wanna do this this would be wrong
because i wanna start measuring right at
the edge
right at the edge of the bank so i wanna
do it like that
and i see okay the length of the bank
well how much is that well you see this
right wall right over here it's right at
four
right at four meters
so this is going to be four meters long
let's do another one
what is the length of maria's backyard
in meters drag the ruler to make the
measurement so once again you don't want
to do something like this where you're
starting to measure
before the garden even starts you're
starting to measure too late you want to
measure right at the edge right over
there so that's where the garden starts
so that's where your ruler should start
measuring one two three four five six
seven
eight looks pretty close let's see
it looks pretty close to eight
eight
meters right over here
so yeah this this length of this is
eight meters it looks pretty close i'll
say eight
all right let's do one more of these
what is the length of the tray of
cookies in centimeters
and when they say length they mean the
length actually means the longest
dimension if you have a width and a
length and so the longest dimension of a
tray of cookies is going to be this this
side right over here you don't want to
measure you don't want to measure that
side up there that would not that would
not be the length the length if people
don't tell you otherwise it's the
longest dimension so we want to measure
so we want to measure let me make sure i
don't lose my ruler we want to measure
we want to measure along the top or
along the bottom and we see
that it is once again we don't want to
do this that would be starting the ruler
too far to the left and you don't want
to do this starting the ruler too far to
the right you want to put it right at
the edge right over there my ruler isn't
perfectly straight and we see that this
cookie tray is
it is right at about eight centimeters
eight centimeters
and we're done